what's this uh nick uh we talked when
little brows
uh joined the culture corner about
possibly putting together a king and a
sting
album and uh he really went ham on it
and it's
it's happening dog i've heard some of
the tracks the one with him and chin
about hannah baron it is fan fighter
get down on them oh man all the way to
alabama
there's some original yeah
there's some original songs by brows and
there's a bunch of the our favorite
submissions from the show
uh it's gonna drop someplace on vinyl or
digital copy
late november early december wow if on
november
1st uh we're going to open up fi or cap
the meet me at 20 tier on our patreon at
500 spots and if you're
a patreon member on november 1st you
will get the first run
of those sh uh shipped to you
that's cool and this is the debut album
off it uh we filmed it a couple weeks
ago this one's called chappelle lacy
it's a good name for a song lebron turn
that [ __ ] up
chappelle down oh damn got some video
[Music]
vixen
crazy
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[ __ ] is whack hey you sound crazy
[Music]
degrees and some sandals yeah
[Music]
i'm sorry guys yeah go ahead go ahead
and get back to work
look at nick in the background
[Music]
oh
little brown is so talented
gang man
[Laughter]
isn't that video great yeah they crossed
you that's cool man
you guys did a great job
so there's more to come with that and he
mentioned paul paul if you want to
feature on this album hit us up if
you're watching i'm trying to get mike
stud on there too
and we want to get jelly roll on another
one anybody
yep that'd be crazy man that's crazy man
if i'm alive to see it i hope
i don't feel good you don't you'll be
fine man
so we're gonna do a limited edition
first run only a thousand copies
500 we'll go to patreon the other 500
will sell but it's going to have artwork
that
will never be used again if we decide to
print more vinyl wow